oh husbands who love me
there's definitely like a double
standard when a female has multiple
partners oh my God she's such a she
sleeps around how is it agreed
[Music]
okay so in this video we are going to be
watching
a promotion for a show so let's make
sure that we're talking about it well
I'll stop and start it so we talk about
it so we don't get [__] with by
YouTubes okay good idea so talk over
what we see yeah so this is a show about
being a [__] cuck okay no this is my
show I'm in what is it called seeking
brother husband here we go brother
husbandry is the practice of one woman
having multiple husbands but those
husbands cannot have any other partners
oh no
what Emery Emery look that's one
directional polyamory yeah but this is
like a gender discriminatory polyamorous
it's an agreed to perhaps yeah you know
what this is this is mental illness dude
so what this is what drama
husband to love me
there's definitely like a double
standard when a female has multiple
partners oh my God she's such a [__] she
sleeps around how is it agreed
so she so all the women in this show
have multiple husbands
oh situations not all ones this makes me
upset
shares a room with him the [__] none of
them's a loser man I let my partner you
know can be with brother husbands my
partner fall for another man right
before my eyes
that guy's not gay he might be bi he
might be uh apparently don't judge a
book by its cover I think it's just a
lot of people are just really confused
of what's going on yeah I think some
covers are pretty indicative of what's
inside I wouldn't be surprised if he
came out of the closet what is happening
to see me holding hands with somebody
else or like kissing someone say AOC
Ard
[Music]
I love the music I love the [__] TLC
music
she looks so happy
her Partners but the dudes can't that's
the idea
that's the setup because it seems like
the guys aren't really down it's like
we're getting jipped huh yeah the guys
are quietly down but they're really nice
I see why this is a hit dude I watched
the show I'm watching this TLC comes up
with some dope [__] well they have a
show called MILF island or MILF Manor or
something that sounds great are you for
real no I'm serious I think yeah MILF
matter yeah yeah they got some good
shows though man the premise is it's
like eight moms and then their sons are
on the show and then they all date each
other dude that's The Learning Channel
for you that's crazy but this is like I
honestly expected I didn't I always I
honestly expect to be mostly white
people but I'm pretty surprised that
they got black like truffles today they
found black cooks too it's crazy isn't
it I just didn't think that was a thing
they're making shows off like porn
search words now dude like this is like
cuck [__] they have the MILF stuff now
this is ridiculous yeah they're just
buzzwording these shows into existence
that's how I found it seeking brother
husband yeah no that makes sense because
if that's what people are searching and
that's what they're interested in I
guess that's [__] thing
it's just about sex that's definitely
not
okay it's about financial support right
yeah it's like a gold dig two people
because all those guys probably make
under 30k but put together they're a
rich man but they put together the
average lower middle class now we got a
six-figure household because we got
seven people in it
completely smart by the way inflation
dude
things really started to get awkward the
Indian or black you can't tell me
see he did this dude
what she said I wish I could be
everything you need but I can't swapped
out and I don't feel like it's a spot
that well that's because you're not
getting swapped out
so the guys aren't fully cool with it
right now
they should call the show gaslighters
The Gaslight Express yeah I feel like
this is really selfish
seems like none of these are working out
who would have thought well then you
wouldn't have a show if it was working
out that's true yeah that's true
[Music]
wow
seeking brother husband pick a better
name oh that might be the best name yeah
it is
the dump thing too is like we look at it
like oh they said they're not allowed to
have other partners they're only allowed
to have that wife as a partner but like
they could still cheat like yeah that's
still a thing no matter what kind of
relationship you're in I can't believe
they didn't call it seeking brother
[__] band it's right there
or like seeing Brotherhood [__] oh
that's not bad thank you hot as [__]
how's [__] hus [__] yeah that's
even better you could drop the singing
brother oh this [__]
[Applause]
I got I just gotta watch the show to
understand the dynamic right now you
gotta try it dude you just have to try
it I think we saw the whole season
already I think I didn't see enough yeah
that's true I do it does make me want to
watch that show whatever can you imagine
being the one that she doesn't really
want to [__] but enjoys crying on oh I
know so she's like you're my husband so
I can like
cry with you and he's all like what am I
gonna get [__] [__] she goes I don't
use you for that do you think the guy
who just wants to rail [__] but has to
deal with the guy crying in the corner
is just kind of like God damn
guy crying in the corners like I just
want a real [__] but like I gotta deal
with the other dick in the room I can't
I can't help but notice that when I see
the trailer for the opposite where it's
like a man with polyamorous like
multiple wives yeah that seems like it
works better I say goodbye I say good
for that guy yeah that looks natural you
know what's funny is they're they're
saying how like yeah no one bats an eye
when um it's the other way around and
I'm like what are you talking about
everyone shuns that those people
Mormons where they do okay it like even
within their Community they're like
that's old-fashioned we don't do that
[__] made it illegal nobody
plus plus they're saying like oh when
it's the other way around it's like you
know a girl has like two husbands
something like she looks like a [__] I'm
like I don't see her as a [__] I just
see the hus [__] as [__] 100
because when you watch those guys you're
like those poor bastards yeah let's
shake your head and there's one thing
that everyone is thinking of when you
see a little lady sit between two dudes
and you know they're all like in a
couple do you think about her getting
DP'd the whole time yeah and that means
Director of Photography
power Eiffel power that's not bad a
little rotisserie chicken I always
picture I also picture all three of them
going on the date and there's always at
least one dude that has to sit in the
back seat
she's also paying he's paying for both
of them the guy the guy who gets the
door for the other guy and the girl oh
that's the man but then but then the guy
as he's walking through the door he
still daps him up that's a really great
working relationship and he seems like
the two guys never like each other right
I know it seems like they don't
acknowledge each other I'm not going to
talk to that guy I'm gonna talk through
you when one guy was talking the other
guy's like looking this way dude there's
that one guy who's like yeah it was a
little awkward at first like you know
here they're like boning through the
walls but you get used to it oh what
dude or like or like you guys you guys
stay in the same room no I have my own
room and then they stay in the same room
together oh I have my sheds which they
built for me it's really nice
has a window and even a door have you
ever known anybody who was in a throuple
not personally only normal cheating but
never throttle honestly normal cheating
is like just do that please I know of
one through a friend but I don't know
them personally but when they're
explaining how it came together it feels
like this show it feels like a chick
that got what she wants and then just
two dudes that hate their lives oh yeah
that's what it feels like they're stuck
with their [__] and the the chick and
the dude had a kid and now the kid now
has two dads oh no and the biological
dad is cool with the kid calling the
other Dad Dad too it's just like he
calls him Dad too no no I'm just like
Daddy one daddy The Secret of the Ooze I
always I always try to play like Devil's
Advocate to see like if I could expand
my brain and I'm like
I don't know how much Ayahuasca I need
to take to be able to understand that's
a no for me dog that'd be open-minded
some some back in the day yeah you got
to try it back in the day right like
some tribes were uh not monogamous and
the the basically any guy that hit the
girl and when she gets pregnant they're
all dads so if the kid is born they all
have to take responsibility as fathers
what are they all railing her yeah oh so
and all the bats are they really in
other chicks it's historical then oh see
like for me that that makes sense it's a
community where it's either everyone can
get it whoever wants to do it yeah it's
like that there's no like so the rule is
basically if you hit it she gets
pregnant and then the baby comes out
then everyone who did it with her is
basically the father do you feel like
that was only back in the day though
because like I don't know civilization
improved and modernized and that's why
it doesn't work couldn't prove it yeah
everyone looked kind of the same anyway
that's true you know and then Maury came
out you are not the father and then the
dude
[Laughter]
when the girl immediately gets up and
runs in the back and the camera guy is
like Tethered to her like he has a rope
around his waist and he's like faster
I love that [__] dude yeah when the
rules only go one way that's when it's
weird man hey should we as a JK but what
about harems though those are so cool if
everybody's down I guess it's not that
bad I think as as the JK family and as
the the viewers we should all watch the
show together and then just kind of like
that'll be fun and it just commented
just follow along dude I think this one
I'm invested in we should watch it on
the Discord and have some kind of
viewing thing with it yeah you know how
we do lives on the Discord we'll just do
that like whoever's joined the patreon
who's a part of our live streams
we can watch TL TLC shows together
shouldn't make promises we can't keep
but that'll be a fun idea though I mean
we already live stream on patreon so
they can talk to us there I kind of want
to watch this with taika and watch his
reaction and he's probably like Papa I
don't know what's going on
[Laughter]
Papa why do they got the two daddies can
I have two
oh yeah dude what have I done